estimate the solution to 582 thousand
two hundred five plus six hundred and
ten thousand eight hundred fifty nine by
first rounding these two numbers to the
nearest thousand so we're going to round
each of these numbers to the nearest
thousand and then add them and that will
give us an estimate to this solution so
let's do each of these numbers so if we
start off with five hundred eighty two
thousand two hundred and five five
hundred eighty two thousand two hundred
and five we want to round to the nearest
thousand so you go to the thousands
place and you go one place below that if
that's five or greater round up if it's
less than five round down this is less
than five the two here is less than five
so we want to round down we are going to
round it down so it's going to be five
hundred and eighty two thousand we're
just going to round it down to two
thousand we're going to get rid of all
this two hundred five here five hundred
eighty two thousand when we rounded it
down to the nearest thousand now we have
six hundred ten thousand eight hundred
and fifty nine so six hundred and ten
thousand eight hundred and fifty nine
same drill go to the thousands place
that's the zero right there look one
place below the thousands place this is
that eight right there if this is 5 or
greater you round up less than five
round down it is 5 or greater eight is
greater than five or you could even be
five and we'd still round up so we're
going to round up in this situation
we're going to round up so we end up
with six hundred six hundred and instead
of six hundred and ten thousand we're
rounding up to six hundred and eleven
thousand six hundred and eleven thousand
so we've rounded the two numbers to the
nearest thousand now we're ready to add
so let's add them let's add the two
numbers 0 plus 0 is 0 0 plus 0 is 0 0
plus 0 is 0 2 plus 1 is 3 8 plus 1 is 9
5 plus 6 is 11 if there were more places
here we would carry the 10 the the 1 in
the tens place but there isn't so you
can just write an 11 here and so
we are left with put a comma every third
digit 1 million 193,000 which is our
estimate and the whole reason why this
is useful is if some were to give these
numbers to you and you have to do it in
your head it's hard to add these whole
numbers but you might be able to do 582
plus 611 knowing everything is in
thousands so it allows you to do things
in your head a little bit easier when
you round and then you and then you
estimate the sum of the rounded numbers